apple abandonne son port propriétaire
lightning pour s'ouvrir
c'est un grand progrès je crois que pour
le coup on peut le dire ils n'ont pas 10
est une révolution apple sourds apple
intègre un port usb type c est ça pour
le coup c'est une vraie révolution
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler d'apple des
nouveaux produits qui ont été annoncés
par apple tim cook a fait l'annoncé de
plusieurs produits assez intéressant en
tout cas une vraie mise à jour du côté
des mac et il ya eu aussi une vraie mise
à jour présentait depuis un petit moment
pour l'ipad pro alors l'ipad pro c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que au-delà
de la mise à jour matérielle s'attendait
bien qu'il allait finir par arriver
on est vraiment qu'il ya un
positionnement qui est choisi par apple
pour dire que ne lie pas de trop au
final n'est pas une tablette l'ipad pro
et un ordinateur et c'est vraiment ça
qui est intéressant parce que
effectivement cet ipad front et une
tablette va pas se mentir je pense que
vous le savez mon le sait tous on l'a
compris à l'ipad pro est une tablette
mais l'ipad pro finale comme ce qu'on
peut retrouver d'ailleurs avec des
surfaces pro du côté de chez microsoft
on n'est plus vraiment sur des tablettes
comme on l'imaginé à quelques temps
juste une tablette la tablette est
redéfinie et là elle se positionne de
plus en plus comme un ordinateur et
c'est vraiment là dessus qu'il faut
qu'ils s'étaient fait de la partie cook
alors on va passer rapidement sur les
specs j'ai mes petites notes là
forcément je n'ai pas encore eu le temps
de tout apprendre par coeur c'est pas
faute de matériel qu'il faut retenir à
mon avis ce qui est plus intéressant le
'chase' disparaît on voit arriver
fayçal dit ça on s'attendait aussi
depuis un petit moment donc ça s'est
vraiment bien je drake ipad procme un
petit peu au goût du jour par rapport à
ce qu'on a eu l'année dernière au niveau
des iphone ça peut paraître une
évolution assez logique
ce qui est par contre assez sexy c'est
que quel que soit le sens dans lequel va
le positionner votre ipad proulx
el-fayçal divin marché et ça c'est
plutôt cool
du coup ça permet d'avoir des zags
retravailler la même largeur de bord de
tous les côtés vous avez un produit
symétrique c'est vraiment ce qui est à
nu sur ce produit
en tout cas je trouve assez bien réussi
extrêmement fins 5,9 mm contre 6 9 mm
avant et une baise 465 grammes qui dit
fayçal diddy forcément de nouveaux
gestes on a pris les nouveaux gestes
avec l'iphone 10 l'année dernière
là il ya également deux nouveaux gestes
au niveau de la navigation
forcément pour le multitâche pour ouvrir
le centre durant trois fins pas mal de
nouveaux gestes qui sont assez logiques
qui seront six à saintes utile par
rapport aux utilisateurs de l'iphone 10
ont un écran et liquid
il a donc d'alipay c'est du lcd liquid à
tina c'est le nouvel écran qu'on a sur
l'iphone qui sert ici
pas d'écran oled j'imagine pour les
coûts de produits c'est déjà un produit
qui est assez cher qu on va en parler
tout à l'heure vous avez deux versions
sont une version 11 pouces 2388 par 1668
pixels soit une version 12,9 pouces 2732
par 2048 pixels dans les deux cas à 264
pixels par pouce et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on marque la taille
du châssis réduits à dix et à d'écran
qui sont assez optimisé nous annonce ou
du bord à mort il reste quand même des
jolies bordure sur l'écouté ça serait
compliqué de les cacher depuis façon vu
qu'à cette caméra 'prudent' avec son
capteur de 7 millions pixels
ça serait difficile de se passer de bord
noir
à moins d'avoir mis une encoche ce qui
n'est pas le cas c'est d'ailleurs plutôt
bien intégrés et plutôt bien réussi là
dessus de la part d'apple en termes de
performances ça y est une nouvelle puce
qui vient de faire son arrivée c'est la
puce à 12 x bionic
on continue dans les puces bionique avec
le north island jeunes pour travailler
au niveau de l'intelligence artificielle
optimisation des performances en
utilisation de l'autonomie de la réalité
augmentée qui toujours mise en avant il
ya eu un vrai faux cul ce qu'était en
avant sur des applications gourmandes
sur un photoshop en allant vraiment
cherché avec énormément de call avec de
l'autocar aussi avec des jeux vidéo à
des graphismes époustouflants ont sans
doute fait une présentation il nous
montre le meilleur ce qui marche le
mieux de toute façon on dit très bien
que ce riz lâcher comme ça
la performance va être au rendez vous ça
va pédaler à fond ça je crois que c'est
clair ils n'ont d'ailleurs les mêmes
performances que dans une xbox phonix ça
reste à voir
m6 annonce une batterie pouvant tenir 10
heures d'autonomie
vous allez toujours quatre haut parleurs
vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 la caméra
principale les temps 12 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture de f 1.8 peut filmer jetant
4k à 60 images par secondes vous avez dû
agir enfin une caméra extrêmement bien
pousser qui fonctionne bien dans la plus
longue ligne droite de ce que ça nous
faire apple en termes de photographie de
qualité en tout cas de photographies
grosse nouveauté et ça c'est aussi
intéressant c'est l'arrivée de l'usb
type c'est au revoir le port lightning
ça y est il est fini il s'en va l'usb tu
y arrives sur ses ipad pro les ports
thunderbolt 3 avec 2
c'est également sur le macbook air mais
ça je vous en parle dans une autre vidéo
et c'est vraiment intéressant parce que
c'est vraiment un virage qui est fait
par apple en termes de compatibilité
pour se brancher avec des boîtiers pour
cheikh des moniteurs avec pas mal de
choses qu apple abandonne son port
propriétaire lightning pour s'ouvrir
c'est un grand progrès je crois que pour
le coup on peut le dire ils n'ont pas
dit c'est une révolution apple s'ouvre
apple intègre un port usb type c est ça
pour le coup c'est une vraie révolution
concernant le style et on a un pays s'il
deuxième génération magnétique qui est
aimanté directement sur cette tablette
comment pour retrouver notamment sur la
surface pro esquisse un passé vous avez
une collectivité son fils ce qui fait
vous avez de la recharge sans fil par
induction directement pour recharger
votre stylet vous avez aussi des petits
raccourcis tactiles s'envole style et
fait un double tap ça va vous changer
votre mine d'y mettre un pinceau vous
mettre un stylo vous pouvez aussi
paramétrer des raccourcis notamment dans
photoshop a inspiré qui va un peu plus
loin et qui peut paraître assez sympa
vous avez aussi l'arrivée d'un nouveau
smart qui bordent
voilà ça c'est un peu pour l'écosystème
une machine qui a l'air d'être vraiment
fluide rapide
on imagine connaissant déjà les ipad pro
maintenant ancienne génération
la fluidité et la rapidité un produit
qui était déjà franchement bien assez
cher en reconnaître mais par contre
vraiment bien et là du coup puisque je
vous parle de prix il assez cher je
crois que là aussi c'est relativement
cher parce que si on prend le prix le
plus élevé c'est-à-dire un ipad pro 12 9
pouces configuration un terrain parce
qu'on peut monter jusqu'à 1 tera avec
une version 4g vous êtes à 2119 euros
l'ipad procédure extrêmement cher parce
qu'effectivement vous le savez il ya
effectivement deux versions la version
wifi la version 4g et entame de stockage
on a quatre possibilités sont 4 gigas
250 gigas 512 igae on va même jusqu'à 1
tera vous commencé sur une version 11
pouces 64 giga wifi à 899 euros
on est dans des tarifs cohérent là
dessus et on va sur la version je vous
ai dit la plus chère 12 à 2,9 pouces 1
tera version 4g 2119 euros c'est le
grand écart on est à bout
12 effectivement il ya du stockage ça
marche mais c'est extrêmement cher à
noter que le pen s'il coûte 135 euros
là on est sur un tarif médian par
rapport à peu retrouver sur le marché et
le smart key bord folio pour le 11
pouces coûte 199 euros consacré une
relativement cher et pour le 12ème round
pouces 219 euros
on sait quand on achète apple on
n'achète pas moins cher mais en tout cas
ils ont un d'être plutôt sympa c'est des
produits qui sont disponibles en
précommande dès aujourd'hui et vous
pouvez recevoir à partir du 7 novembre
prochain bon du coup là dessus forcément
on va se retrouver avec les emoji avec
les mii muji ça c'est plutôt cool est ce
intéressant de la part d'apple de la
voir en famille dans les ipad trop lent
pour l'instant on ne parle que les ipods
fraude on imagine que petit à petit les
gains pour se renouveler votre touch
heidi va forcément disparaître on a
retrouvé à terme fayçal dit un peu
partout ça me paraît quand même assez
normal j'imagine que la prochaine
évolution
la prochaine étape ce sera un écran oled
mais là j'imagine que s'il l'avait mis
les prix allaient continuer à grimper en
flèche
ça sera un petit peu compliqué
probablement peu rédhibitoire met un
écran de 11 pouces ou 12 9 pouces oled
ça risque de coûter une blinde pour moi
ce qui est vraiment intéressant dans
cette vision de l'ipad pro au delà de se
dire c'est un bon appareil c'est un
appareil d'entrée sur papier a l'air
d'être intéressant connais la qualité
d'apple d'un petit effectivement une son
cher ça marche extrêmement bien il ya
toujours la qualité derrière elle la
robustesse mais ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est la vision parce qu'il
faut se projeter plus loin
aujourd'hui on a un marché où
effectivement on a des smartphones on
voit qu'on a des tablettes et on voit
qu'on a des ordinateurs donc on a quand
même trois produits au quotidien donc
quand vous achetez les trois produits
d'une seule et même marque
ça fait depuis jean marc ça finit par
coûter extrêmement cher ton plus que la
tablette a vraiment réussi à trouver sa
place dans nos foyers et l'idée d'apple
c'est de se projeter en dix ans cet ipad
pro n'est pas une tablette c'est un
ordinateur un ordinateur qui a
réellement sa place donc on imagine que
les laptops comme ça continueront à
exister
plus peut-être pour un usage pro je sais
pas un peut être que des gens qui vont
aimer ça
mais ya une vraie belle alternative qui
se fait avec ses tablettes est passé
devant mener partout avec soi on peut
l'utiliser pour du multimédia on peut
utiliser pour pas mal de choses pour le
boulot
la prévenue est enfin c'est vraiment un
accessoire extrêmement complet ça nous
permet d'entrapercevoir là où vont nous
emmener des marques comme apple dans les
années à venir
et croyez moi mon avis on n'est pas vous
ne s'en prenne à d'ailleurs dit moi ce
que vous en pensez comment vous trouvez
vous comment vous les trouvez ces ipad
pro de 2018 est ce que vous êtes content
est ce que vous êtes déçu est ce que
vous pensez au final que le boulot fait
par apple la suisse est une bonne chose
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'arrivée
de faith heidi enfin moi je ne reviens
pas sur sa taille pas de trop
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'abandon
du port lightning et l'arrivée l'usb
titre et vous marquez tout sans
commentaire on reste connectés on va
parler d'apple continue à parler de la
peur aussi de parler de beaucoup de
marques plein de choses plein de
produits intéressants qui sont arrivés
donc on fait une seule chose on s'abonne
aura se connecter à bientôt sans qu'ils
sachent mieux vous embrasse
[Musique]